[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm Todd.
This is Arun.
And we're glad
you could join us.
Let's talk a lot about
Firebase Analytics.
So I'm guessing many of
you are app developers,
and you're wondering
how Firebase can
make your life a little easier.
Maybe you are
BigQuery aficionados
and you're wondering how you can
put your elite BigQuery skills
to use in a Firebase world.
Or maybe you just wanted
somewhere kind of quiet
to check your email,
and that's fine too.
We won't judge.
From up here, it kind
of looks like you're
taking really good notes.
So keep doing it.
So I'm going to start by
explaining what Firebase is--
because I think a lot of people
still think of it as just
a real-time database,
and honestly Firebase
is a whole lot more than that.
It's really a whole
suite of services
available on iOS and
Android and the web
designed to make it easier for
you to build successful apps.
And these include everything
from a cross-platform
Notification Service with
Firebase Cloud Messaging
to Remote Config,
our fun little tool
kit that lets you change the
look and feel of your app
from the cloud.
I don't know if you've
heard about the cloud,
but I think it's going
to be big, mark my words.
To-- yes, the Realtime
Database, to a whole bunch
of other features
that I'm not really
going to talk about today
because at the heart of all
these features is this thing
here, Firebase Analytics.
That's why we drew it
in the center like.
It's like a visual metaphor.
So I think anybody who's
worked on a successful app
knows that analytics are
really important to building
on that success.
It's really the best way to find
out what people are actually
doing within your app.
And by finding out what users
are doing within your app,
you can make it better,
like, you can find out
places where users
are getting stuck,
if they're features
that they're not using,
or if there's parts
of your app that
are way more interesting or
sticky than you anticipated.
And then you can adjust
your app accordingly,
according to what your
users are actually doing.
So there are a lot of
libraries out there designed
to help developers
measure what's
going on within their app.
Google Analytics was one
of the earliest of these,
but it was really targeted
more for websites.
And you can kind of
see that in the way
it was designed, in
the way it's set up.
It's got a lot of web page-y
terminology in the reports
and in the way it
processes information.
It also limits you to about
10 million hits a month
before you need to upgrade
to an Analytics 360
subscription, which we know for
a lot of small indie developers
might be a bit of an issue.
Firebase Analytics,
on the other hand,
was built from the ground
up to be mobile-centric.
It comes at no cost to you and
supports an unlimited volume
of hits, no matter how many
millions upon millions of users
your app might have.
So from our
perspective, this really
is the way that
mobile app developers
should be measuring what's
going on within their app.
So let's take a closer look at
how Firebase Analytics treats
data, because if you
are going to be dealing
with this data as a
BigQuery developer,
it helps to know what it looks
like underneath the hood.
So Firebase Analytics is
really all about events.
Nearly everything you want
to record within your app,
whether it's a user opening
it for the first time
or making in-app purchase,
visiting your store
or completing a level is going
to be recorded as an event.
Events have names.
And then they also have
up to 25 key value pairs
or parameters that are
passed along with them.
And these parameters
can be used to store
any kind of interesting
data about the event
that you as an app developer
might want to know.
Some events within
Firebase Analytics
are recorded and submitted
automatically for you
by the mobile libraries.
These are things like
in-app purchases,
or the user updating
their operating system,
or your users opening your
app for the first time
on the library.
It can automatically
detect these events
and submit them for you.
Then there's a whole
bunch of suggested events
that are predefined
by Firebase Analytics,
and these tend to
be events that are
fairly common to a number
of different apps--
things like adding an item to
a card in an e-commerce app
or conducting a search.
Now, unlike the automatic
events on the previous slide,
you'll need to submit
these events yourself.
And don't worry about the
tiny font for those of you
taking pictures, hoping your
resolution is good enough.
We have documentation
that lists all of these.
But I think the majority
of the events that you
will be sending within Firebase
Analytics are custom events.
These are events that you define
specifically for your app,
and you can define up
to 500 different types
of custom events.
And really, this can be anything
that's relevant to your app.
Maybe that's like completing
a workout in a fitness app,
or unlocking an
achievement in a game,
or viewing a recipe
in a cooking app.
And that's basically
events in a nutshell.
The other important
type of data I
want to cover for Firebase
Analytics is user properties,
and these are well, properties
associated with a user, hence
the name.
So the idea behind
user properties
is that as the user interacts
with your app over time,
you might learn more about them.
You might learn what
their fitness goal is
for those of you
with fitness apps,
or what their favorite musical
genre is for those of you
with music apps, or
how they pronounce
gif, which as we can see
here is the correct way.
And so the idea here is that
you can use this information
to filter your events by
these user properties.
Like, maybe you're curious
if your yoga enthusiasts
are spending more
money within your app
than your weightlifters.
And so you can go ahead and
filter your in-app purchase
event by this fitness
goal user property,
and you can start to
see for yourself who's
spending more money in your app,
the weightlifters or the yoga
people.
And then maybe you can
adjust your marketing
spend accordingly.
And that's basically it.
Just by using events
and user properties
you're able to supply
Firebase Analytics with all
the information it
needs to give you
some pretty useful
information about your app
in the form of some very
nice-looking graphs.
So in fact, let's take a look
at some of these right now.
So these are some of
the basic dashboards
you'll get, essentially,
without any other work
as soon as you integrate
the Firebase SDK.
So here we've got active users.
These are users
who are interacting
with your app over a
defined time period,
in our case the last 30 days.
We have average revenue
per user, known as ARPU,
and average revenue per
paying user, known as ARPPU,
which is my favorite
acronym ever.
We have retention
cohorts, which shows you
how frequently people come
back to your app over time.
And this is usually broken up
into weekly groups or cohorts.
We have user
engagement, how much
time people spend
within their app
when they're actually using it.
Your top in-app purchases.
And if we scroll
down a little bit,
we can see who your users
are, where they coming from,
and a whole bunch of
other useful information.
But actually I don't want
to spend a lot of time
on these initial
dashboards because I'd
like to spend a little more
time talking about events.
So any event that
your app records,
whether it's a Firebase
automatic event or a custom
event that you're logging, shows
up here on our events panel.
And if we were to click
through on one of these,
we could start to see more
details about this event
as it occurs within our app.
So let's take a look at
three of these examples.
This first report here is for
the in-app purchase event.
And you can see we have,
through a series of graphs,
the number of times this event
occurred in the last 30 days.
We can see the number
of unique users
or I suppose more
accurately app instances
that have performed this event.
We can see average
events per user,
and then the total
value of purchases
during this time period.
We also have a few custom
reports for net purchases.
In this case, we can see
what the top products are
that our users have purchased,
what our average purchase
price per item was.
And then if we scroll
down a bit you can see,
again, we get some nice
demographic information
about the users who are
performing these events,
as well as an events
per session graph, which
sometimes comes in useful.
And then you can see
we have similar reports
for our level-up event.
This is one of those
suggested events
that Firebase
Analytics already has
predefined for game developers.
And also an unlock
achievement event.
This is a custom event that the
developers of our sample game
Bingo Blast have
created on their own.
And so we can
learn a fair amount
just by looking at
these stock reports.
Like, my in-app
purchase report will
let me know what products
are most popular.
And I can do things
like filter this report
by some of our user properties.
For instance, I can filter
our in-app purchase event
by operating system version.
And that can start to inform
some important decisions
like how backwards
compatible do we want to be?
Like, if it turns out
users who are on OS 8
are still spending money
within our game, well,
then maybe that makes
sense to kind of make sure
that we can still
support those users.
And we're able to give
you these kind of reports
for no cost, no matter how many
millions upon millions of users
your app might have.
So maybe this sounds
too good to be true
and you're thinking
what the catch is,
and I'm glad you're silently
thinking that to yourself
because that's the rest
of this presentation.
So I want you take a
look at this graph again
or this report.
You can see that our in-app
purchase event gives you some
very nice information about some
of the custom event parameters
that it gets in--
in our case, the product
that was purchased
and how much those items cost.
You also see, for a predefined
event like our level-up event,
we get a nice little
bar chart that shows you
what new level our
users have reached
when they reach this event.
But then if we go back to our
unlock achievement event here--
and this is a custom event--
we don't see any information
about the actual achievement
that our user has unlocked.
Like right now if we want to
know what achievements are most
popular, or which ones
are harder to unlock
than we've anticipated,
or get any information
about these parameters that are
sent with this customer report,
we currently can't get
any of that information
with this report.
And basically here's the deal.
The way Firebase
Analytics works is
that every day the
service gets millions
upon millions of events
for all of your apps,
and every few hours they
process this raw data into these
generated reports for you
to view at your leisure.
And while these reports
are kept around for you
to view whenever you want,
this raw data is not,
which means that if you
want to run complex ad
hoc queries on historical data,
or export your data to use
with other analytics
packages, or simply run custom
reports that you don't get
out of the box with Firebase
Analytics, you're going to
need access to that raw data.
And that's where
BigQuery comes in.
I'm guessing here at
a Google Cloud event
I don't need to give you a whole
lot of detail on what BigQuery
is, but for those of
you watching at home,
it's Google's data warehouse
in the cloud that's
designed to run very
fast queries over very
large amounts of data--
data like the kind of
analytics event data
an app with a whole bunch
of users might generate.
And so the idea is that when
you link your Firebase account
with BigQuery, which you can do
through this handy little panel
in the Firebase console--
it's under Settings.
It's a little gear icon.
You can look for it--
then when all this analytics
data from your clients
gets sent to Firebase
Analytics, a copy of that data
also gets sent to BigQuery, and
this happens in near real time.
BigQuery stores this data in
sort of a temporary intraday
table, and then at the
end of the day copies
it over to a more
permanent table
that you can keep for
as long as you'd like.
And so you can query
these intraday tables
if you want something
resembling real-time analytics,
or it can look at
these historical tables
if you want to look at
historical data over time.
Now, I should note that if
you want to use BigQuery,
it's not entirely free.
You will need to upgrade your
Firebase project to the Blaze
pay-as-you-go plan.
And on the BigQuery
side of things,
you will need to pay
for the data you store,
the cost of the real-time
streaming inserts,
and the usage.
However, if we were to take
a look at a sample game like
Bingo Blast, which right now
has about 20,000 monthly active
users across iOS and Android,
records 70 different event
types and 10 different
user properties,
right now our data storage
charges come up to about $0.60
a month to store the previous
10 months' worth of data.
We're also paying
about $0.12 month
to insert that data into
BigQuery in real time.
And then if we were to run
a simple query across say,
a month's worth of Android
data, that costs about 1/10
of a penny.
If we were to run 50
queries like that every day
across both Android and iOS,
we'd be looking at about $3
a month.
However, it turns out
that BigQuery offers you
one terabyte of usage
data for free every month,
and this falls well
under that free tier.
So this part actually
costs nothing,
for a grand total of $0.72.
Now obviously huge
disclaimer here.
These figures can
vary considerably,
depending on how much data
you're collecting, how long you
keep it around
for, and how often
and how complex you're
making these queries.
But at least for our sample
app, linking to BigQuery
did not involve a
huge financial hit.
And I should also note that
there are some tools in place
to set quotas or alert
you if pricing goes over
what you're expecting.
So looking back
at our sample app,
there are a few
questions that I want
to be able to answer that I
can't right now from Firebase
Analytics.
First, give me some
more information
about what achievements
were actually
unlocked by this unlock
achievement method-- event.
Second, while it's nice
that I can filter my events
by a single user
property, I'm actually
interested in filtering
by two user properties.
Like, for example,
what if I want
to see our spend
virtual currency
event for our users
who speak English
and also have power ups?
Filtering by two user
properties at once
is not something I can do right
now with the out of the box
reports.
Third, I want to generate
a few custom reports that
span both my Android and my
iOS data, and in theory maybe
I want to combine this
data with data coming in
from another analytics
tool that my app is using.
And then fourth, I
want to see what's
causing my users to spend
virtual currency in my game.
Sure, I can see reports on
this spend virtual currency
event itself.
But what are the events
that lead up to that event?
That's something that would
be pretty valuable data to me
as someone who wants my
users to spend money.
So these are all areas where
analyzing the data in BigQuery
might help.
And now before we do that,
before we get in the demos,
I do want to explain what our
data is going to look like.
Because I don't know
about you, but I sometimes
think of BigQuery as
a giant SQL table.
And if you've played with
any of our public sample data
like New York City Taxi
rides or Hacker News posts,
this is kind of
what it looks like.
And maybe you knew
this, but I didn't.
BigQuery is really much more
sophisticated than this.
The rows in BigQuery aren't
really single rows that
consist of one line of data.
They're more like individual
JSON trees that are all
crammed into each
row, each of which
can contain key value pairs
and arrays and objects
and arrays of objects.
And that's important
to understand
when you're looking at
Firebase Analytics in BigQuery,
because one of the first
things you might assume
is that each row in
BigQuery corresponds
to a single Firebase
Analytics event,
and that's actually
not the case.
More often, a row
in BigQuery will
consist of a set of
user information,
and then probably
two or three events
bundled together for that user.
So let me explain by showing
you what our actual data
scheme looks like.
So our user info
section here contains
a few straightforward key value
pairs like first open time
and some kind of unique ID
that you as an app developer
might provide.
But then they also obtain
a number of nested objects
that all have their own
set of key value pairs,
things like the device
that the user is using,
their geographic location, the
traffic source information--
what marketing campaign brought
them into your app, and so on.
We also store user
properties that we
have associated with this
user in the Firebase Analytics
library.
And these properties
are basically
stored as an array of objects.
These objects in turn
contain the name of the key
as well as the value.
And the value
itself is an object
that has an end value, a string
value, double value, and so on.
And you'll find that in
practice most of these
are null, except for
the property that
contains the actual value
you're interested in.
This basically
allows you to store
any number of user
properties in any format,
and they're kept inside
your BigQuery table
in a consistent manner.
And the nice thing about
keeping your user properties
in a big nested array like
this is that there's basically
one less join that you need to
worry about later when you're
building up your queries.
And you'll start to see that
in the demo in a little bit.
So then in addition to
all this user information,
there's some event information.
And as I mentioned
earlier, BigQuery
tends to store these
Firebase Analytics events
as an array of three or four
event objects all bundled
together in the same row.
These also contain some
straightforward key value
pairs, like the name of
the event, and the time
stamp when this event
occurred within your app.
But then they also contain
an array of event parameters.
And just like user
properties, these parameters
have keys and values.
And these values themselves are
their own little objects that
contain string value, end
value, double value, and so on.
And that's pretty much
the data structure
that you're going to be
dealing with in Firebase
Analytics in BigQuery.
So with that in mind, let's
revisit my initial list
of questions that I couldn't get
answered by Firebase Analytics
alone.
And we'll start with
that first question,
what achievements are
actually getting unlocked
with this event?
This is something our
game design team really
wants to know.
So luckily, querying
custom parameters
like this within
BigQuery is something
that really any halfway
decent SQL developer
could put together.
Turns out, though, I
am not that developer.
Honestly, I barely know
what I'm doing up here.
Luckily, I'm here
with Arun, who does.
So he's going to walk us through
some live examples on how
to perform some of these queries
using some actual Firebase
Analytics data in BigQuery.
So Arun, why don't
you take it away?
ARUN VENKATESAN: Thanks, Todd.
Hi, everybody.
So in order to answer Todd's
questions of which achievements
are getting unlocked in
the app, let's actually
see some Android code that
you need to implement.
The Android snippet here shows
us the unlock achievement event
being added to
Firebase, with the name
of the achievement, coins100,
being added as a custom string
parameter.
Similarly, when the user clicks
other achievements in your app,
such as user power
ups, daubs and coins,
you can add those as a
achievements names as well.
A few slides earlier,
Todd showed us
the scheme of a Firebase
record in BigQuery.
The Firebase event and
the parameter names
that we just logged
in Android snippet
are shown in BigQuery
record, as seen here.
The unlock
achievement event name
is stored as a value in the
first events name field,
and the corresponding
parameter is
stored as a value in the nested
parameter string value field.
Let's now do a quick demo.
So this is BigQuery
SQL editor, and we're
going to use standard SQL
for all our examples today.
The query results
show us the count
of each unlocked achievement,
indicating the most popular
achievements in the app.
This is just the results that
we just ran a minute ago.
As seen here, the top
achievements in the app
are coins 500 and daub, both
of which are equally popular.
Let's now look at the
actual query itself.
Note the unnest syntax here.
In the from class,
the unnest, it
threads through an array
of Firebase objects, which
are event objects in this case,
stored in the event dim record,
and produces one
row for each event.
That's just a convenience
function for you.
Let's move on to
another example.
Earlier in the
presentation, Todd
showed you the events report
in Firebase Analytics console.
Here is how we can generate
the same report in BigQuery.
As seen here, the results
show the top events
and their even counts.
The spend virtual
currency is actually
a second most popular event
in the app, which is great.
Let's look at our
other open questions.
The [AUDIO OUT] asked
about filtering events
by multiple user properties.
In our example, we will filter
the spend virtual currency
event by the device
language and powers,
which are both user properties.
The result shows that users with
device language set to English
and had power ups
in the app spent
$2,250 virtual dollars in
the app for a total of 218
times, which is great.
Here is the query
that we just executed.
The query is in two parts.
In the first part of the query,
we apply the max function
to all of the rows so
that user properties
are applied uniformly to all
bundles of events for the given
user.
And in the second
part of the query
we take the results
from the inner query
and only select those
events for which both
the user property
criteria are satisfied,
the power ups and the language.
Let us now look at
other open questions.
Let's now see how to combine
our iOS and Android data.
This is a cross-device query.
And we'll shortly see it.
The results show that while iOS
tablet users a greater than iOS
mobile device users,
the results are just
the opposite for Android
users, which is interesting.
Here is the query
that we just ran.
It shows how the data from
two different data sources
can be combined in BigQuery.
In this example, notice
how we not only join
data across our iOS and
Android apps, but in addition,
we also joined the iOS
and Android app data
across multiple dates.
Now, it turns out
that our sample data
us from a purely mobile
app, but in some cases
you might also have a
web app, in which case
you're probably tracking your
analytics in a tool like Google
Analytics.
It turns out that
with BigQuery you
can combine data from Firebase
Analytics with other providers,
such as the data that you
get from Google Analytics.
You can join your iOS, Android,
and your web data in BigQuery
to determine user behavior
across all of your apps.
Let's now look at probably
the most important question
in our minds, which is on
how you might figure out
what's causing users to
spend money in your app.
In order to answer
this question,
we will build a
sequence of events
by user that leads up to
the user actually spending
money in your app, what we might
call a custom event funnel.
Here is a query that generates
a sequence of three events.
You can modify this query to
include any number of events
you want in the funnel.
The partition by class
breaks the input rows
into separate partitions
by app instance ID,
which is a proxy for
user ID in this case.
And the lead navigation
function returns the next event
based on an ordering
criteria, which in our case
is the event time stamp, thus
creating a series of events
ordered by time stamp.
The results for part
one of our query
shows the three events
for a given user.
The user IDs have been
masked for privacy reasons.
As noticed in the
interim result,
the second event
in the first row
appears as the first event
in the next row and so on.
Let's now look at
part two of the query.
We'll apply results from part
one to part two of the query.
In the second part of our query,
we simply define our end event
as the spend virtual
currency event,
since we would like to determine
what users did before they
spent money in the app.
This query calculates the number
of users and the frequency
with which this funnel
has been navigated.
Let's look at the results.
And it shows you what makes
users spend money in their app.
And you can see all
of the different paths
that users took before they
spent money on your app.
For instance, a lot
of users spent money
after completing a
round, which is great.
On the other hand, it also
shows you that you the developer
could do more to entice
your users to spend money
after spinning a slot
or after leveling up.
All good so far, except
that the product folks
don't want to deal with
SQL, so what's the solution?
Google Data Studio.
Google Data Studio
turns your raw analytics
file-based data into informative
reports that are easy to read,
share, and fully customizable.
You can now create no-cost
and unlimited charts
and other interactive
visualizations.
In order to help
you get started,
we provide two
sample reports that
are based on a comprehensive
set of metrics and dimensions
available throughout
your BigQuery schema.
You can use these
samples as templates
to quickly create their own
reports and visualizations
based on your own
app's raw data.
And let's see how to do it.
We'll now use the events
sample report in our demo.
So let's first take a look
at some of the charts.
So there's some basic dashboards
and then reports based
on events and also conversions.
This is all in
the sample report.
Let's use this template,
create a new data source,
specify our BigQuery project,
select the Android data set,
and select events.
Once we connect this data,
we'll add it to the report.
There you go.
So this was your
sample data here,
and this was your own
data, but generated
with the same reports.
You did not have to
type or enter anything.
You just had to go
through a few clicks.
It's that intuitive
and that simple.
Google Data Studio also
lets you create reports
based on custom SQL queries,
and we'll see how to do it.
We'll create a report using the
events report query that we saw
earlier in the presentation.
So I'm going to copy the
SQL query that we wrote
for the events report, and
in the Google Data Studio
homepage, select Data
Sources on the left.
Select to create
a new data source.
Specify a Custom Query.
And select your data set.
I'm pasting the query
here that I just
ran in the BigQuery SQL editor.
And it's a standard SQL,
so take off legacy SQL.
And I create a report.
Once I've ordered this
data to the report,
I can now create nice charts.
So I'm going to do a pie
chart for the events.
Let's see how that works.
There you go.
So with just a few clicks
you have a nice pie chart,
which will show you a nice
visual illustration of all
your events and the event
count, thus making your product
and marketing folks happy.
To recap, Firebase Analytics
is at the heart of Firebase
and is a no-cost
and powerful tool
to meet all of your
mobile analytics needs.
Combined with BigQuery
and Data Studio,
you have a powerful analytics
platform and querying
engine in your hands.
Thank you.